and what else does it say well the
report is quite damaging a sense that
employees were aware or at least it
should have known of those lapses in
quality control it says the company at
one point even halted global safety
audits in order to save money so the
report was issued by Democrats on the
Commerce Committee and it comes ahead of
a Senate hearing that's happening on
Tuesday now Senator Bill Nelson of
Florida who'sa highest ranking Democrat
on the committee said in a statement
that the more evidence they see the more
it paints a troubling picture of a
manufacturer the lacked concern so this
report telling of incidents that happen
as early as two thousand seven but
Takata not taking any sort of action for
over a year Estacado responded Takata is
saying that this is not correct they're
disputing the findings the report is
based on thirteen thousand documents and
they were collected in order to go ahead
with this investigation so Takata is
saying that those documents contain
errors and some of the emails that were
put in the investigation were taken out
of context so Takata saying that they're
committed to proper manufacturing
practices and to the safety of their
employees and also the driving public
and it's speaking of which where our way
on these airbags and the recalls those
airbags right that can shoot retinol zat
passengers once they deploy well they're
linked to now eight deaths and over a
hundred injuries so the latest
confirmation came from Honda just a few
days ago about the latest casualty that
happened last September in LA now jewel
brangman was driving a two thousand one
on the Civic when she got into an
accident and she was killed now eleven
different manufacturers are recalling
cars and now we're hearing that more
than 34 million airbags have to be fixed